let's meet the creators and some of the
cast of the book of life right now
starting with director Jorge Gutierrez
the producer of the film mr. Guillermo
del Toro
she is the voice of Mary Beth in the
film Christina Applegate stars as the
voice of Xibalba Ron Perlman
and as The Voice thought what team mr.
Channing Tatum the book of life is a
film unlike anything you've ever seen it
is hilarious and touching and bizarre
and wild and Jorge tell me about your
vision for this film because it is
really unlike anything I've ever seen
Anatomy to film do before oh the the
original sort of inspiration for the
movie was my grandfather when I was a
kid he I was five years old and he sat
me down and he gave me these words that
have stayed with me forever
which were jorgito never let the truth
get in the way of a good story and so
that got me in trouble and my grandma
hated that saying but it kind of became
what this movie is about it's all the
stories of my family and it's sort of a
recipe book with all the tales that I
heard and and we're serving into the
world it's it's great to have that the
Latin culture represented in an animated
film it's such a big colorful
adventurous way Guillermo
welcome again the whole age first of all
I want to show you something here that
says please be aware that many members
of your audience may be under 18 years
of age I got for me so watch your mouth
I will not curse alright tell me you'll
spell out the words tell me how you got
involved with the project you know well
one one day [ __ ] has showed off of my
house with her with a big carton of
tequila a big trunk I still have the
prong and I hadn't drunk the tequila I
may add but he showed off whether all
the art and with a pitch for the movie
and this is about seven years ago and I
heard the pitch and then I started
telling Jorge well what if we changed
the story this way or that way do you
like this and we had a great chemistry
now we have great chemistry also for he
was sweating very much and he looked
great I thought he was gonna have a
heart attack I wanted to calm him down
but we started a journey because what I
saw was such a beautiful set of images
and I produce movies when I or direct
movies when I feel they need me you know
I feel we better protect this baby so
that it can make all the way to the end
of the line as beautiful and as pure as
we can make it and I think we in that
degree we have succeeded it's a gorgeous
magical movie it is gorgeous it is
magical I think before we go any further
we should take a look at a little
footage from the book of life I in no
way condones rug use of any kind but I'm
gonna get so stoned before I see this
movie Jorge I love the use of
contemporary music that you do that you
do in the film that's a great idea where
did that come from I grew up in Tijuana
here mixed next door yeah all the
American music
I saw it go south and I you know became
the soundtrack of my life
and it's all these songs or songs that I
grew up you know creep was one of those
songs that I felt and I I felt like I
create but I didn't belong all these
things and I put it in the script I
still
I never thought the bands were ever let
me use it I imagined at some point some
lawyer would tell me to take it out but
the bands got behind the movie in the
music and just a friend is one of my
favorite songs of all time so great to
see that in there and speaking of
someone who lets you use his music
I think I saw biz markie these songs
connect generations yeah it's a party up
in here now in Hall age I'll tell you
that right let's talk about your
character a little bit he seems to be a
bad dude he's just misunderstood nice
he's sweetheart like snakes he's been
around a few thousand years and what's
his old lady's name come on I'm we're
done with this man's name I already but
anyway
no no I didn't mean that oh that's a
couch for me yeah
Oh nobody nobody open your mouth okay
it's all between us all right anyway
he's larger than life he's he's used to
wheeling and dealing and he's awfully
good at it but he's he's in this
relationship with this very formidable
counterpart who they adore each other
but they're you know they it's a few
thousand years so you know their idea of
spicing things up a bit it's a little
bit kind of you know expensive and he's
a lot of fun to watch and he's a lot of
fun to play and I had a ball
well you're a brilliant voice actor you
do great work animation always truly
Janney was this your first foray into
voice acting the animation had you done
mom I did Superman and Lego that was
really just an hour me and Jonah making
fun of each other did they come to you
with the roller did you have to audition
know where they came came to me and told
me a story and I jumped at it right away
I mean it seems so punk rock movie with
this backdrop I heard you put your own
twist on the character when you're first
doing your readings is that true maybe
unintentionally but yeah because I have
obvious mixed in you know sure the
answers right so
and Christina Mary Benton's the first
character I think we need in the film
yes can you talk about her her role in
look of life I am the storyteller
basically you it opens on this museum
and Mary Beth is a tour guide there and
she runs into some little naughty kids
and she wants to give them an adventure
so she takes him into this special room
and she says I want to show you the book
of life so basically I'm the narrator
and the storyteller and the mommy but
there's also a twist and she's a teeny
tiny waist
I love you back we have questions can we
get a couple questions from the audience
let's go to the microphone and to see if
we can squeeze in a couple questions
from the crowd I'm sure there's a lot
you'd like to ask these guys up here hi
there what's your question I have a
question for Guillermo hi I really love
your work here well thank you Pacific
Rim based basically convinced me to
become a director so I really look up to
you oh thank you and I was wondering
what made you jump on this project like
specifically because all of your other
projects you know held boy Pacific Rim
and Pan's Labyrinth they're all so
different from this and I was wondering
what the difference is and pros and cons
well I think that is very important
first of all to do things that call you
and they need you and that you feel you
have a need to protect and but at the
same time things that will give you a
sense of form and creation and life and
when you stumble on that project you
feel a kinship like Jorge's like my twin
brother we come in the same package like
the ping windows marinara is like
to people to round things together you
know and and and I truly felt like huge
kinship the visuals are and the
fairytale like story in a way and the
profound roots that it has him in our
culture all that I felt I was I feel
privileged to be part of it and I
ultimately what is funny is each each
movie you do presents to an audience and
other side of your personality when I
did Cronos people were surprised when
they saw Hellboy horribly they said oh
is that the same guy there was mag 1 or
Hellboy very different at the same time
I feel that everything I get involved in
I have a kinship with me the orphanage
made this big hell with a Pacific Rim
whatever it is there's there's a huge
chunk of heart in there greasy and
clogged with cholesterol heart
nevertheless thank you for your question
hi there what's your question hi
first of all comment to Grande I almost
said burgundy because I saw a Christina
but love play more all love Hellboy I
just want to say amazing but just a
question about the environment creating
help away versus creating this
underworld the artistry kind of the
whole vibe how did you how did contrast
those two worlds how are they similar
I call it was for wrong but the question
was for you ah Daniel oh yeah you don't
love me that was love understood oh okay
now I think that the creation I mean a
producer is there whatever kinship
exists to support the director to
challenge him to support him to nurture
him to nag him all of that so the
question is a better answered my aura
well creating the world I just like with
these guys I kind of thrive on
collaborating and so the the lander
remember the the sort of the dead world
you guys saw I work very closely with
Paul Sullivan our art director and to
Medinah a production designer
sundar kilos my wife designed all the
female characters the movie I designed
all the male characters so I kind of it
kind of just got into my brain in the
they saw although I showed them
everything I love I'm referencing
videogames and operas and you know my
grandma's version of stories and it's
all rows and 2 rows I mean this might be
my last movie so I figured I'm gonna put
everything in this is it the look of the
film it seems as if you've also borrowed
from Latino culture in terms of art and
how you how you applied that can you
talk a little bit early the you know
there that that is very dear near to my
heart I got married on day the bed
because I wanted my best friend who had
passed away to be my best man so that
was the day I knew he would show up and
I wanted my whole family so I really
truly love folk art and I love seeing
the artisans hands and the imperfections
I think that's what the dirt gives it
flavor is what I always say
and so the look at the movies very much
a love letter to those things the end of
that is a very beautiful beautiful the
iconography is everywhere you see a
skull with a sombrero you know it's Day
of the Dead and as cool as you know low
bar culture and and punk culture all
these things have borrowed from it my
favorite thing about it is what's
underneath that and it's the core
beliefs of the holiday which is as long
as we tell the stories of those who came
before us as long as we tell their jokes
as long as we sing their songs as long
as we cook their dishes they're with us
and they're inside of us and the moment
we don't talk about them they're gone
leaving us windows we have time for just
anything else banished
we will not translate that last remark
Emma we have time for one more question
then you're it sir what's your question
hi my name is Mike this is for Channing
Tatum Channing you're known for your
good looks in your physicality what
wasn't about just your voice that they
that you thought you could add to this
role in this movie
they told me I was gonna be able to have
a amazing mustache in this movie I
really felt like my voice seems like it
needs a mustache so that was it you can
hear it you can hear the mustache in
your head feels very supple and lush
doesn't know I mean look I mean the
truth of it is is that you know I
haven't got to play in this world before
and and to get to work with these
artists I mean and I mean artists of the
highest so they it's like working with a
net you almost can't do anything wrong
they want you to just trust them as long
as you trust them and just give it all
and it's called animation for a reason
and you try to be really animated even
though you're not on screen and and
that's really it just try to bring a
little heart to something that you know
you don't actually get to the body I
think that another thing that Channing
does uniquely and he knows that in this
movie is that he he has the physical
part but he has an incredible very very
adorable vulnerability you know and
that's an accessibility and a humanity
that it comes through the boys well is
just a big party to Harvard appreciate
is beautiful is also his career is
fantastic I would have made more money
cuz I would have charged to put my
clothes on and I would have been a
billionaire but I'm a little offended
that you didn't pose that same question
to me yeah
Christina you're hot you're hot don't
you
you